let's think a little bit about what it
means to multiply two-thirds
times six
one way to think about it is to
literally take six two-thirds and add
them together this is six two-thirds
right over here and if we wanted to
actually compute this this would be
equal to well we're going to take these
six twos and add them together so we
could view it as two times six
two
times six
over three
two times six over three which is the
same thing of course as
two four six
eight ten twelve
twelve
thirds
twelve thirds and what is 12 thirds
equal to well we could rewrite 12 as so
this is equal to we could rewrite 12 as
3 plus 3 plus 3
plus 3
over the yellow 3
and this is going to be the same thing
as
let me do it like this so i don't have
to keep switching colors this is going
to be the same thing as
three thirds
plus three thirds plus three thirds plus
three thirds and each of these are
obviously a whole each of these equal
one that's one that's one that's one and
that's one so this is going to be equal
to
four so that's one way to conceptualize
two-thirds times six
another way to think of it is as
two-thirds of six
so let's think about that let me draw a
number line here and i'm going to draw
the number line up to six
so
what i care about is the section of the
number line that goes to 6.
so that looks pretty good so this is 1
and 6.
so if we want to take two-thirds of six
we can think of this whole section of
the number line between zero and six
as the whole
and then we wanna take two-thirds of
that so how do we do that well we divide
it into thirds to three equal sections
so that's one equal sections two equal
sections and three equal sections and we
want two of those thirds so we want
one-third and two-thirds now where does
that get us that gets us that gets us to
four so we get obviously to the same
answer would be in a tough situation if
somehow we got two different answers
either way two-thirds times six or six
times two-thirds either way that is
going to be equal to four but there are
two different ways of viewing this this
first way is literally viewing it as
two-thirds six times and this way is
we're taking a fraction of the number
six we're going two-thirds of the way to
six which would get us to four